MAYOR de BLASIO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Sean: DRAWING IS NOT,
LARA TRUMP AND A BABY AND TWO
WEEKS.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU.
SO WHAT YOU WATCHED THIS
INTERVIEW WITH ME AND ME AND
BILL de BLASIO.
YOU SAW THE WHOLE THING.
IT WENT OVER 60 MINUTES
SOMETHING STUCK OUT IN MY MIND,
NEVER WANTS TO GIVE ANSWERS ON A
LOT OF THINGS.
TO NEW YORK'S AND AMERICANS HAVE
THE RIGHT TO HAVE A GUN IN THEIR
HOME?
WOULDN'T GET ANY ANSWERS ON
ABORTION, A LOT OF THINGS.
THAT'S NOT DONALD TRUMP.
HE ANSWERS EVERYTHING.
>> YEAH, HE IS VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD ON EXACTLY WHERE
HE STANDS ON EVERYTHING.
EXACTLY WHERE HE STANDS ON
ABORTION, THE SECOND AMENDMENT,
HE'S VERY CLEAR HE DOES NOT WANT
TO TAKE YOUR GUNS, HE'S MADE
VERY CLEAR THAT INFANTICIDE IN
NINE MONTHS ABORTION ARE NOT
SOMETHING THAT HE STANDS FOR.
ALAN, I DIDN'T THINK IT WAS
INTERESTING THAT OUR MAYOR WAS
ASKING YOU A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
MAYBE HE COULD AT GUEST HOST FOR
YOU.
BUT NO, LISTEN, I THINK ANYBODY
THAT WATCHES EXACTLY HOW THAT
WENT DOWN WILL TAKE THE SAME
THING AWAY WHICH IS THAT WE DID
NOT GET AN ANSWER.
WE DID NOT --
I DO NOT REALLY KNOW WHAT HE
STANDS FOR EXCEPT TAXING THE
HILL OUT OF THE RICH AND THERE
WASN'T AN ANSWER ON EXACTLY HOW
THAT IS GOING TO WORK OUT FOR
EVERYBODY.
THE REALITY IS THIS PRESIDENT
HAS BROUGHT THE AMERICAN DREAM
BACK AND IT'S BACK UNDER
PRESIDENT DONALD J. TRUMP
BECAUSE WHENEVER YOU LOOK AT THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE THE LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT IN THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY, WE HAVE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF MANUFACTURING
JOBS COMING BACK TO BE FORGOTTEN
MEN AND WOMEN OF THIS COUNTRY,
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT HE'S
DOING IN INNER CITIES OF THIS
COUNTRY, HE REALLY WANTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE PAID
ATTENTION TO.
HE HAS CREATED SOMETHING CALLED
OPPORTUNITY ZONES IMPLEMENTED IN
BALTIMORE, CHICAGO, DETROIT COME
ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY TO BRING
MONEY INTO THESE PLACES TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE CAN WORK AND
HAVE THEIR SHOT AT THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
>> Sean: THIS IS WHY I KEPT
GOING BACK TO --
I GAVE THE OLD, BODY NUMBERS AND
THEY SHOULD BE HAPPY BECAUSE IT
HELPS HIM AGAINST BIDEN.
YOU HAVE 13 MILLION MORE
AMERICANS ON FOOD STAMPS.
A MORE IN POVERTY.
THEY HAD EIGHT YEARS TO FIX IT.
DONALD TRUMP INTO AN END HALF
YEARS, THE BEST EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION SINCE 1969 AND THE
PEOPLE THAT BENEFITED THE MOST
ARE THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN.
I MEAN, I THINK I MADE IT CLEAR
WHAT MY BACKGROUND IS.
BLUE-COLLAR GUY.
AND AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS, WOMEN, YOUTH
AND EMPLOYMENT, TO ME, THAT'S
THE GREATEST SUCCESS STORY.
>> COME IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE
WHAT USE ARE ALSO IS THAT HE
STANDS FOR WHAT SO MANY OF THESE
DEMOCRATS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
STAND FOR.
THEY REALLY STAND FOR FULL
GOVERNMENT CONTROL OF ALMOST
EVERYTHING GREAT IF I HEARD HIM
TALK ABOUT PRE-K, AGAIN, YOU
TALKED ABOUT IT A LOT, BUT THEY
WANT TO RUN OUR SCHOOLS,
HOSPITALS, THEY WANT TO RUN OUR
HEALTH CARE, THEY WANT TO RUN
EVERYTHING.
SOCIALISM AND MOST OF THE PEOPLE
UP THERE STAND FOR THAT.
THEY STAND FOR GIVING FREE
HEALTH CARE TO ILLEGAL ALIENS
WHEN WE CAN EVEN TAKE CARE OF
OUR OWN PEOPLE.
AND SO, I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
HARD FOR PEOPLE TO RATIONALIZE
VOTING AGAINST THEIR BEST
INTEREST AND THEIR BEST INTEREST
IS TO KEEP DONALD TRUMP IN
OFFICE HE HAD WHEN THINGS ARE
WORKING FOR THEM AND NOT GO THE
OTHER WAY BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO PEOPLE.
>> Sean: YOU ARE RUNNING
TRUMP 2020, THE REELECTION
CAMPAIGN.
WHAT'S YOUR TITLE?
>> SENIOR ADVISOR.
>> Sean: OKAY.
HERE'S THE THING.
IN EVERY ELECTION, ALL ARE WE
BETTER OFF THAN WHERE WE WERE
FOUR YEARS AGO?
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ASCERTAIN
THAT ON THE ECONOMY, WE ARE NOT
DROPPING CARGO PLANES OF CASH ON
THE MUELLER'S RUNWAY ON IRAN
WHICH WAS STUPID BUT ALL OF
THESE RECORDS, ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, HE KEEPS HIS
PROMISES, JUDGES, ENERGY, TAXES,
DEREGULATION, TRADE DEALS,
EVERYTHING HE SAID HE WOULD DO,
IT'S NOW WORKING.
AND THEN THE QUESTION IS, HAS
THE PRESIDENT LOST ANY
ENTHUSIASM?
WELL, THE 20 PEOPLE WHO WENT OUT
FOR HIM IT IN 2020 STAY WITH
HIM?
I THINK THE ANSWER IS YES.
THE NEXT QUESTION I HAVE IS, ALL
OF THESE GROUPS, DOES HE HAVE A
CHANCE AT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
BENEFITING THE MOST FROM HIS
POLICY THAT DENTED BENEFIT UNDER
THE LAST EIGHT YEARS UNDER OBAMA
AND BIDEN?
>> I ALWAYS SAY IT.
I THINK THERE WILL BE SO MANY
MORE PEOPLE THAT WILL COME OUT
AND SUPPORT THIS PRESIDENT
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
WHAT MATTERS TO PEOPLE IS MAKING
SURE THAT THEIR LIFE IS HEADED
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
IT'S LIKELY BETTER FOR YOU, AS
YOU ARE SAYING, THAN IT WAS FOUR
YEARS AGO.
IS IT BETTER NOW THAN IT WAS
BEFORE DONALD TRUMP TOOK OFFICE?
SO MANY PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
WOULD SAY YES.
>> Sean: WHAT YOU PEOPLE IN
NORTH CAROLINA THINK OF
AMERICA'S COMEBACK?
>> PEOPLE IN NORTH CAROLINA,
PENNSYLVANIA, OHIO, ALL BECAUSE
THIS COUNTRY, THEY ARE THRILLED
THAT NOW NOT ONLY IS SOMEBODY
DOING THE RIGHT THING IN OUR
ECONOMY THROUGH THE ROOF AND WE
HAVE JOBS COMING BACK, WE HAVE
SOMETHING STANDING UP FOR US AS
A COUNTRY BUT WE HAVE A FIGHTER
AND OFFICE, AND THE WHITE HOUSE,
WHO WE KNOW HAS OUR BACK.
WHO ALL ACROSS THE WORLD IS
LOOKING OUT FOR AMERICANS.
>> Sean: GREAT TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU FOR COMING UP.
CONGRATS.